okay listen up we can use calculus to
find the volume of a sphere what we do
is to split the sphere up in two tiny
cylinders the volume of each cylinder is
equal to pi r squared which is the face
area times the width the X
with the width getting infinitely small
we integrate or add them all up to get
four thirds pi R cubed as L sphere's
volume we can do the same thing to get
the volume of a four-dimensional
hypersphere but this time we add up
infinitely many tiny 4D cylinders they
have spheres for faces and are separated
by a distance DX integrate those it's a
messy integral but we get pi squared
over 2 times R to the 4 as our volume of
a 40 sphere with radius r